in the climate crisis China is both hero
and villain it's staggering economic
rise has been built on dirty development
China is dependent on coal and today
it's the biggest polluter in the world
responsible for nearly 1/3 of all carbon
emissions we have evidence that coal
power plants supposedly canceled are
once again under construction for the
country is also the biggest global
investor in renewable energy the Chinese
Communist Party has thrown its mighty
weight behind green technologies
bringing down costs for everyone so much
so the some wonder whether only an
authoritarian government one unbothered
by the debate and delays of democracy
can meet the challenge of climate change
[Music]
Gansu Province northwest China the old
Silk Road ran through the valleys below
these mountains now it's the front line
for climate change in China
Jojo Chou has been a shepherd here for
nearly 20 years little area here annual
Shepherd slash our sincerity polio the
worse the fukusa tgd hello ever got /
China do que si o si tu parle que are
you a movie
Joe lives and works right under the
shadow of these mountains there are so
many glaciers in Central Asia that are
known as the third Pole after the north
and south but they're retreating
fast these photos show the rate of
change since 2001 millions of people
depend on the fresh water these glaciers
contain this is where the threat to
those glaciers lies more than 1,300
miles east in herve province China's
vast industry runs mainly on carbon in
particular coal one of the dirtiest
fuels around China today emits more
carbon than the US and Europe combined
painted on trees is about as green as it
gets
that's over alliance on fossil fuel
created an air pollution crisis it
cities choked by smog its citizens
increasingly unhappy the Communist Party
pledged drastic action as a response
about 15 years ago China established a
renewable energy law it had a much
greater focus on how does it developed
wind and solar energy clean energy that
doesn't have air pollution that doesn't
have carbon emissions
it went from basically nothing or very
little wind a very little solar to
really dominating the world and both of
those industries and now also electric
vehicles too cuts down on coal Beijing
ordered its provinces to cancel or halt
construction on coal power plants but
building has resumed these recent
satellite images show work resuming on
coal plants across the country
apparently in violation of central
government restrictions this new data
provided exclusively to Sky News by
global energy monitor and NGO shows that
nearly half of all postponed or Council
projects are back in action
but I also wanted to understand the
other side of the story
air pollution has decreased dramatically
and China's three green solutions wind
solar and electric vehicles could have
an even more significant global impact
on climate change they're scattered
across different corners of China here
at the edge of the gobi desert state
intervention has been undeniably
effective from a long way behind china
now has the largest wind capacity of any
country on the planet this area
constitutes the biggest wind farm in the
world
I visited one section run by a
state-owned company and what better way
to see it the climbing 60 metres
straight up last year alone China
installed the equivalent of one large
wind turbine every 62 minutes
it's quite a tiring climb to get up here
but once you do get up here you get a
sense of the sheer scale there are
hundreds of these turbines but thousands
more across Gansu and their scores of
wind pots all across China it's probably
the only country where you can give such
a big effort to renewable wind energy
all under the watchful guidance of the
party ma Li from neon for Guangzhou that
you go Champa how should be made yeah
shall we go again then it's had a joker
jaghana shown that Regina thought this
reduce water tone for higher demand good
Andre let's hello that your town wha
Iago shoulda would young Dida this
region is the poster boy for wind power
in China but even here for all the huge
investment wind still doesn't generate
as much power as fossil fuel stations
the Ordos deserts in Inner Mongolia the
empty dunes have been filled with solar
panels again China is dominating this
industry it is both the largest producer
and installer of photovoltaic cells
worldwide its total solar capacity with
all its farms running would be enough to
power the whole of the UK three times
over and China's support for solar
manufacturers has brought massive cost
reductions for everyone around the world
cutting-edge technology can also breathe
new life into age-old practices
yang moved here last made young you know
China is putting his deserts to work in
other ways too over the last 20 years a
private company called Leon factor with
heavy government incentives has
transformed these barren sands into a
vast OS it is a great green wall built
as a barrier against desertification the
phenomenon that itself contributes about
4% of all carbon emissions
the next stage of greening the desert is
an experimental technique using drones
to scatter specially designed seeds
across dunes so this shows you the
effects of adding trees 1988 at the top
there that's where the dune used to
stand and you can see it's been coming
down and it's also been coming down more
quickly the more trees that are put here
to have an impact on climate change
energy generation is change so so does
our consumption that means heading to
the city china's developments over the
last 40 years has been extraordinarily
rapid with it the mass migration of
hundreds of millions of people from the
countryside to urban areas
Shanghai is a sleek thoroughly modern
marble but 85% of all China co2
emissions come from cities what the
world leads instead is more moments like
this a couple from China's new massive
middle-class buying their first electric
vehicle and not because the environment
is their main concern this brand is
quite new but it's a fancy one yeah
because of the design and also the
technical new technology China's huge
effort in electric vehicles is already
paying off in total last year more than
a million were sold in China more than
the rest of the world put together so
China's role is really important China
is the largest auto market in the world
and it has been for several years the
scale and volume that China can bring to
the market is having a huge effect on
the supply chain so it's hammering down
battery cost is handing down component
costs and its rules are forcing
automakers to invest in electrification
probably much sooner than they would
have without China
there are a staggering 486 electric
vehicle startups registered in China one
of them more established is called neo
their cars are made in this Factory it's
benefited from close ties to the Chinese
government the study lists project of
four years ago and I let Han William Lee
is its billionaire founder dubbed
China's Elon Musk
III I don't think we should ask the
users buy the cars because of climate
change that's not fair
so you better product and more and more
users like your products and surveys and
then that can help climate change so
that's my that's my thinking yes well
the Communist Party has achieved and
renewables is truly remarkable but it is
a complicated hero with its own
self-interested calculations because
this is also a blueprint to dominate the
industries of the future and very much
is an economic calculation you know
these are strategic emerging industries
that's the name for these kinds of
industries within China and they know
that renewables are going to be a bigger
and bigger part of the future electric
vehicles are going to become commonplace
so they want to get their enterprises
their companies to be dominant in those
markets but the authoritarianism that
allows the ponty to mobilize huge
resources without the niceties of public
debate can also be a weakness
the lack of transparency builds into the
political system means even the central
government can't trust local data that
means you need to see the reality on the
ground
I travel to Yulin in northern China this
is China's dirty energy secret the part
of the country it doesn't want you to
see we were followed by unmarked cars
while we investigated the business here
is coal and business is still good even
for small yards like this one I want you
to do such a clean no matter how much
though typically console each other
renewables today only account for 22% of
China's energy consumption 59% still
comes from coal unless China can win
itself off coal all its investments in
renewables may as well be for nothing
the signs are not promising behind me is
a brand new coal mine it's just started
running and for all the fine words of
the Communist leadership for the massive
amounts of money they are spending on
renewables coal remains the backbone of
China's industrial economy and it will
be for some time to come this is a
critical moment for China and the world
no country can make a bigger impact on
climate change but China cannot have it
both ways forever the halo of its huge
renewable investment isn't bright enough
to obscure the dirty reality this
dependence on coal
hero-villain sooner not later China must
decide